those in favor will say aye aye
the vote was unanimous to subpoena or
legally compelled former U.S president
Donald Trump to testify before Congress
about his failed attempt to overturn the
2020 election they're getting into the
capital tonight and his alleged role in
inciting a riot at the U.S Capitol in
the name of remaining in power
we are obligated to seek answers
directly from the man who set this all
In Motion this is a question about
accountability to the American people
he must be accountable
he is required to answer for his actions
Trump has called the investigation a
partisan hoax and is expected to appeal
the subpoena the beginning of a long
legal battle in response to Thursday's
vote Trump ridiculed the committee
calling it a bust and again falsely
alleging massive voter fraud in the 2020
election
the vote to subpoena Trump was the
surprise ending to a string of public
hearings held by a democrat-led
committee that has been trying to hold
Trump accountable for his role in the
January 6th attack committee members say
Trump was at the center of a
premeditated plan to cling to power
which directly led to the violence on
Capitol Hill we
dramatic new video released Thursday
showed lawmakers evacuating as rioters
breached the capitol
as the mob called for her demise house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi and other
Congressional leaders tried to
coordinate a security response it's just
it's just horrendous and all at the
instigation of the president of the
United States while Trump watched and
did nothing according to Witnesses why
don't you get the president to tell them
to leave the capital Mr attorney general
and your law enforcement responsibility
there you go the violence led to several
deaths nearly a thousand rioters have
been charged and dozen sentenced to
prison time Trump has not been charged
the Congressional panel must decide
whether to make a criminal referral
against him and it's working under a
deadline Americans will decide next
month which party controls Congress if
Republicans take back the house they'll
likely shut down the Trump investigation
immediately the committee stands
adjoined
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington